we lost the Senate we lost the house we
lost the White House Nikki Haley
sticking around which is sort of
interesting here is uh her celebrating
her second place finish in New Hampshire
a couple days
[Applause]
ago with Donald Trump Republicans have
lost almost every competitive election
we lost the Senate we lost the house we
lost the White House we lost in 2018 we
lost in 2020 and we lost in
2022 the worst kept secret in politics
is how badly the Democrats want to run
against Donald
Trump Trump's the loser he's a
loser I know that neither one of you
love Nikki Haley uh but I don't think
she's completely wrong about that
specifically and if I was Nikki Haley
and I was running right now I would
certainly you know everyone's saying oh
she should drop out and it's a waste of
money it's like I don't know why you
care about the donor's money suddenly
but of course you have to stick around
to South Carolina like if I was her of
course you do mice what do you think
well first of all I don't think it's of
course because getting your ass handed
to in your home state is something
that's really bad for your career long
term and this is one so that's kind of a
big deal why she might drop out she
clearly doesn't think that's going to
happen well we don't we don't know it's
a month away and the fact that Tim Scott
the senator from that state Endor Trump
is no minor deal but I'm going to diss
with her a little bit in terms of losing
for a lot of conservatives and they're
completely correct if Nikki Haley wins
the Republican party has lost because
it's lost all the things that matter to
it you know she it supports trans kids
she's a huge warmonger I don't think
she's particularly fiscally conservative
what would this woman gain you other
than having a completely uh um castrated
Senate and House supporting a horrible
you know demon in the white house why
would conservatives want this that's not
a win that's a complete loss for them so
even though Tech and I'll just point out
something else that I've called and I'm
positive you both will agree I was very
much for Federman over Oz and every
Republican and conservative I've spoken
to now has seen that I was right so a
lot of times just because someone there
are many reasons why you might prefer a
Biden Administration to a Nikki Haley at
the very least because you'd have space
in Congress to fight the administration
instead of them all having to get their
ducks in a row and do whatever she wants
malice I'll give credit where credits do
because I think you said that on this
show before that election and uh we'll
try to find the clip maybe we'll put
that up um Sarah you know there seems to
be this idea that Nikki is actually just
sticking around because Trump's going to
select her as VP the Bas obviously hates
it but it would kind of be within
Trump's like bag to like poke them in
the eye and be like I need those Women
Voters that we were just talking about
and maybe she can deliver them and bring
some donors along the way yeah the thing
with Trump though is that he is just
such a a loyalist he values loyalty over
all and Nikki Haley has been disloyal to
him for too many years in my opinion for
Trump to turn around and decide that he
wants to to use her as the VP pick I see
if if it's a woman I would see more of
like a Sarah Huckabee Sanders someone
who has been you know loyal to him um
but I mean oh also if Nikki Haley the
longer she continues the worse it's
going to get for her the less and less
likely it's going to be for Donald Trump
to pick her because it's just pissing
him off that she's staying in the race
at this point she's the last one um and
to Michael's point about all of this
just this these neocon conservatives who
just refus to go away it's terrifying to
me I do take a little bit of uh
encouragement in the fact that
apparently a lot of the the Iowa
caucuses who voted for Nikki Haley were
in fact Democrats same thing with New
Hampshire so maybe it's not the full 20%
but it does seem to be like there's this
20% of people within the party who just
want to vote for these these war mongers
and you know these people who are not
conservative at all and so it is a
little bit scary for me to see how many
people are are okay with this type of
person in the party I had thought that
we had gone away from that you know we
told Chris Christie we didn't want him
we told ASA Hutchinson we didn't want
him we told Mike Pence we didn't want
him and Nikki just seems to be the last
one standing and uh you know maybe
that's because she has all of these
Democrat donors who are bankrolling her
which I think should tell you a lot when
you have black rock and you have all of
these Democrats who say we have to do
everything we can not to have Trump in
power and they are instead funding Nikki
Haley's campaign I think that that tells
you all you need to know about Nikki
Haley M mice is is the rub in the
ointment on what Sarah just said there
that even though it is true that a huge
amount especially in New Hampshire of
Independence and apparently Democrats
actually voted for Nikki is the issue
there that when Trump gets to the
general those people don't seem to like
him and he is going to need some of
those people again largely women if he
is going to win